avec Hugo Fray que le temps ne semble
pas toucher c'est l'Amérique de Bob
Dylan nature les grands voyages à ses
côtés à fan de la première heure pour le
moins inattendu l'un des gendarmes du
GIGN les plus connus Christian
proutau bonsoir Hugo fr bonsoir c'est
vrai qu'elle voit toujours quelle
jeunesse vous êtes une insulte à la
vieillesse c'est ce qu'il a dit comment
comment il a dit il a dit une formule
que j'ai beaucoup aimé il ne se voit pas
vieillir alors il ne vieillit pas
exaement mais c'estàdire que effec je
vois pas le temps passer et alors de
façon plus humoristique Renaud dit neige
au balcon oui je connaissais pas ça feu
la cave à la cave oui neige au grenier
neige neige au grenier les cheveux
blancs feux à la cave bah oui c'est un
un capital génétique très très très oui
inoxidable on pour dire de santé très
très très bon et alors tout le monde se
demande comment vous faites Hugo fra
pour être toujours dans cette forme à
bientôt 80 passé hein bientôt 80 ouou 4
fois 4 x 20 ans je crois que je suis au
sens propre du mot un vrai naïf naïf ça
veut dire naturel et naturel c'est ve
dire près de la nature c'est-à-dire que
je ne je n'insulte pas la nature avec
des drogues avec des avec des
exagérations je suis pas un extrémiste
je suis gourmand c'est vrai que vous
avez des tablettes de chocolat comme on
dit des musques à faire palir ce de 30
ans ils sont tous jaloux on le voit non
non non j'ai j'ai j'ai pas tablette de
chocolat ah si ça c'est ah oui ça je
peux taper mais euh mais je je devrais
d'ailleurs je vais m'y mettre c'estàd
quand pour pour parce que c'est naturel
vraiment tout est naturel tout est
naturel oui je fais pas beaucoup de
sport mais au départ j'avais plein peu
d'handicap quoi vous étiez un enfant
souffreteux comme on dit rachitique
franchement on a du mal à à imaginer à
le croire ça je suis gaucher j'écris de
droite à gauche mais la
scène continuellement je vous assure
c'est un sport parce que il y a une
chose que je dois dire ça fait en gros
50 ans de carrière ouais hein sur 50 ans
de carrière je n'ai jamais cessé de
chanter sur scène jamais alors quand
même assez marginal tout au long de
votre vie même parmi les chanteurs ou je
crois que et et sans aucune prétention
je dirais que vous faites pas d'un d'un
loup ou d'un renard vous faites pas d'un
loup ou d'un renard vous faites pas un
chien les animaux domestiques c'est une
spécificité je suis pas domestique moi
je suis naturellement et la vie ne vous
a pas domestiqué non pas vraiment je ne
suis et alors d'abord parce que je n'ai
pas choisi ce métier je n'ai jamais rêvé
d'être un chanteur célèbre c'est rare
c'est rare oui vous rêviez ben moi je
rêvais de je je métais j'envisageais
pour moi un destin beaucoup plus modeste
je rêvais d'être VG ou goguin alors je
me voyais misérable dans un atelier avec
un un poil à bois ayant à peine de quoi
manger donc je voyez je me VO voyez une
vie très modeste mais finalement pas si
modeste que ça parce que quand même mes
idoles c'étaent des génies et mais quand
même la vie que vous avez vous a comblé
c'est ça qui est complètement injuste
moi j'ai rien fait pour devenir une
vedette rien j'ai pas levé le petit
doigt et donc n'ayant pas du tout cette
ambition la réussite que j'ai est est
complètement injuste parce que c'est en
général c'est le travail qui paye et là
moi j'ai pas du tout travaillé pour pas
tout jamais jamais je vais être honnête
j'avais perdu complètement ma voix parce
que je je gagnais ma vie depuis plus de
10 ans dans les cabarets et j'avais
perdu complètement la voix par l'émotion
terrible le chagrin terrible que m'avait
que j'avais subi avec la perte de mon
frère qui lui était Francesco Francesco
qui était né pour être une très grande
vedette internationale qui aurait dû
être chanteur une voie d'opéra
magnifique et donc avec ce frère qui
était tellement doué pour pour le champ
c'était normal que moi je préfère de
choisir le silence de la peinture c'est
vraiment à la mort au suicide de votre
frère Francesco que qui a eu une une
cassure oui je suis resté sans voix et
comme je gagnais ma vie en chantant ça a
été très très dur et à ce moment-là j'ai
rencontré une femme
extraordinaire qui s'appelait madame
Sandra et qui m'a fait travailler pour
essayer de retrouver cette voix là dans
cette période là j'ai vraiment travaillé
mais pas pour devenir une vedette
simplement pour pouvoir chanter pour
pouvoir gagner ma vie j'ai été sauvé par
le fait que j'étais marié que j'avais
deux enfants et que et que Madame Sandra
m'a aidé à à retrouver le la voix le son
le et le souffle dire que c'était votre
frère aîné hein de 18 mois et de 18 mois
c'était mon frère qui m'avait élevé
puisque mon mes parents avaient divorcé
et je sais que je crois être tre venu
dans votre émission une fois et je
pouvais pas aborder même le souvenir ça
a été très long maintenant ça va j'ai
réussi mais c'est voilà je je je deviens
adulte vous croyaez que c'est comme
ça l'on voit qu'on devient adulte oui
quand on arrive à contrôler ses
sentiments quand même voilà c'est voilà
il a une belle gueule ouais magnifique
magnifique aujourd'hui il a été une
vedette de cinéma c'est évident parce
qu'il avait un charme fou
1,83 très Vell très beau et puis une
voix de une voix de de chanteur d'opéra
en fait c'est votre modèle naturel oui
mais il était c'était trop il était trop
trop extraordinaire pour que je puisse
lui ressembler alors moi je au contraire
je disais non moi je vais faire de la
peinture faire des choses dans le
silence la sculpture lui c'est la
musique et alors assez
extraordinaire alors que je n'avais
jamais parlé de de quoi que ce soit je
m'abusais à pianoter c'est un peu ce que
je voulais quoi n'importe quoi et un
jour je me souviens mon frère lui
Francesco m'a dit toi tu seras
concertiste je dis mais pourquoi tu dis
ça je sais pas lire la musique je sais
pas jouer de piano tu seras concertiste
il avait entendu il avait une vision une
vision et je crois que que effectivement
je suis devenu ce qu'il a voulu c'est
formidable ça non ben je crois que ça
existe ça c'est ma première
guitare je lui avais donné quand il est
parti au Canada émigré
puisque c'est là-bas qu'il est mort
voilà il est mort là-bas il était tombé
amoureux d'une jeune chinoise très jeune
et très rapidement les parents de la
famille de cette jeune fille ont dit il
n'est pas question que vous fréquentiez
notre fille et bon
mais on peut pas expliquer un suicide
uniquement comme ça il y avait d'autres
raisons je ne sais pas la fragilité mais
c'était un très grand artiste et mais
qui était parti aussi là-bas pour faire
carrière c'est moi qui avais décidé mes
mes deux frères puisque on devait partir
tous les trois eux ont été pris par le
service d'immigration et pas moi parce
que j'étais trop trop jeune et que
j'avais pas de diplôme ah donc vous et
eux sont partis et vous vous êtes resté
c'est pour ça que c'est lourd c'est pour
ça qu' très lourd mais j'ai
réussi à transformer tout ce ce capital
négatif en positif et donc c'est au
début des années 60 hein que vous faites
remarquer exactement 59 mon premier
disque voilà après les cabarets
l'Eurovision oui je classe 3è non pas
avec le printemps revient en
1963 3 3 ou 4 ou 3 je crois vous voyez
pourquoi je reste jeune c'est que j'ai
oublié les dates et vous êtes lancé
ououi quand les gens me disent vous avez
pas la nostalgie de ces années 60 que
j'allais vous demander donc pas du tout
je dis qu'est-ce quelle horreur les
souffrances qu'on avait là les gens se
rendent pas compte quand je jouais de
cet instrument une sorte de autoarp j'en
jouais à ma façon j'avais des doigts en
sang quand même il y avait du plaisir à
être sur scène ou pas à ce momentlà
est-ce que je vais avoir le courage de
vous dire que j'avais du plaisir parce
que je gagnais de l'argent ouais c'est
lié à ça c'était gagner de l'argent
réussir sa vie vous étatait déjà père de
famille on avait femme enfant on
revenait en disant je vais pouvoir leur
donner à manger et leur donner une vie
correcte c'était ça le bonheur mais le
bonheur euh artistique à 100 % c'était
c'est c'est un peu faux c'est pour ça
que vous étiez tellement différent des
autres c'était l'époque justement salut
les copains et que vous étiez en marge
de non non parce que d'ailleurs c'est
Renaud qui dit les autres avaient l'air
de garçon coiffeur ce qu' n'est pas
gentil pour les autres je peux expliquer
ma façon de m'habiller d'abord le le
jein c'est un pantalon de paysan c'est
un pantalon d'ouvrier c'est un pantalon
de type qui vit dans un train dans dans
les voitures qui couche par terre qui
fait n'importe quoi mais vous n'avez
rien du paysan et de l'ouvrier puisque
vous venez d'une famille quand même oui
vous avez grandi plutôt à nei dans des
beaux quartiers maman aristocrate
espagnole c'est une grande famille et
d'où ça vous vient de votre père non bon
papa c'està dire maman bon papa le baron
de cobios d'ordiran qui était un homme
de la terre alors je disais ensuite le
les bottes les bottes c'est les les
soulers sans laasset ah encore pratique
toujours pratique oui oui parce que le
petit garçon que je suis dyslexique
parce qu'on n pas assez dit gaucher et
les gens qui sont gauchers ont du mal à
comprendre les choses alors on expliquer
comment on faisait un nœud je comprenais
pas je dis allez plus tard quand je
serai grand je porterai AC des bottes et
puis derrière ce symbole pratique il y a
aussi un symbole philosophique les nœuds
pas de nœuds j'aime pas les nœuds dans
la vie pas d'attache pas d'embrouille je
dir pas d'embrouille oui parce que des
attaches vous en AZ des attaches je n'ai
que ça je n'ai que ça mais pas
d'embrouille en fait tout est très
concret très concret les vêtements
gagner de l'argent au départ pour
assurer donc vie de famille parce que
Mar est très jeune vous êtes Mar àelâ le
pain du je me suis marié à 22 ans et le
premier enfant
enfant 23 ans 24 ans oui oui tout de
suite on a tout de suite tout de suite
deux filles et puis l'obligation de
gagner le pain du foyer al le pain du
foyer c'était deux trois cabarets tous
les soirs et une femme qui qui acceptait
Hélène qui accepter ce métier de vous
laisser partir sur les routes euh
c'était pas son c'était pas son idéal le
le show business c'était pas du tout son
truc pas du tout pour ça qu'elle est
resté en retrait tout le temp éit en
retrait ça c'est c'était un peu un
handicap pour moi fait que après sur les
années elle s'est retiré de plus en plus
puis voilà mais moi j'ai continué à
faire la route et puis aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai une jeune compagne qui
s'appelle Muriel ça fait quelques années
maintenant oui oui et qui est une muse
qui me qui m'inspire qui me donne
beaucoup de d'énergie qui m'inspire qui
m'accompagne sur la route finalement
aimé de deux femmes c'est ce qui fait
que vous êtes si jeune oh mais si
j'étais aimé que que de de deux femmes
ça serait bien quel sex
symbole mais comme tous les chanteurs
est-ce que vous avez connu vous
HUG la période où les filles étaient
complètement déchaînées oui oui oui
c'était bah oui ça c'était les années 70
70 à 80 c'était les années après 68 quoi
libération sexuelle et cetera bon ça
paraissait normal à l'époque et
certaines de vos chansons ont changé la
vie de vos fans grâce à Céline Céline
existe je n'en dis pas plus parce qu'il
a une rencontre
surprenante j'imagine votre surprise
quand célineon vous a raconté cela le
destin a voulu que cette cette ce bébé
doit la vie à cette chanson et oui et
qu'elle va donc lui donner le nom de
Céline et que finalement Céline Dion va
être elle-même toute sa VI tout son
destin sera d'être une chanson il vous
arrive d'autres histoires comme celle-ci
que le public vienent vous raconter
voilà cette chanson a été tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours je reçois
du courrier avec des gens qui me dis
m'avait aidé à vivre à survivre et ces
témoignages je les garde évidemment
parce que forcément on se pose des
questions moi qui ne voulais pas être
chanteur moi qui n'ai jamais cherché à
la célébrité je me suis souvent demandé
parce que j'ai vu des gens avoir
beaucoup plus de succès vendre beaucoup
plus de disques avoir voilà et je me dis
est-ce que ce que tu as fait c'était
vraiment utile et c'est quand je vois ce
courrier que je me dis bon
ben avoir finalement ne pas être en tête
des des palmarès ou des comment on
appelle ça des h PARAD ne pas être le
plus grand vendeur tout ça c'est pas
c'est pas très grave mais être avoir
pénétré dans le cœur des enfants avoir
fait chanter les enfants et avoir
redonné du courage à ceux qui n'en avait
plus c'est le seul titre de gloire alors
vous avez été Hugo l'un des premiers
chanteurs pour les causes humanitaires
ce spectacle c'était le organisé par har
Lafon pour la lutte contre le racisme et
surtout en présence de Martin Luther
King c'est le sommet de ma
carrière à l'époque je réalise pas mais
regardez d'entre mon sourire et son
sourire il y a quelque chose que je peux
pas oublier parce que maintenant chaque
fois que je le vois prononcer son fameux
discours
pas m'empêcher d'avoir les
larmes c'est comme ça et c'est votre
plus grande fierté moi la lutte contre
le racisme je l'élargis non seulement le
c'était pas que le blanc contre le noir
c'est pas le musulman contre le Juif
c'est le jeune contre le vieux ou le
vieux contre le jeune c'est le
l'intelligent contre l'imbécile c'est
toutes les ségrégations toutes les
exclusion c'est vraiment le le thème qui
me révolte le plus de tous tous les
mensonge que qui nous entoure et qui
font que les hommes se se se haïsent en
général la haine elle elle se nourrit du
mensonge et et le racisme c'est un
mensonge alors véritable passionné quand
même passionné par la vie passionné par
des tas de choses le cheval bien
évidemment et puis surtout vous avez
renoué avec vos premiers amours la
sculure et la peinture VO voilà il y a
10 ans bonsoir Christian proto ravi de
vous recevoir alors juste pour vous
présenter c'est vous qui avez fondé il y
a 35 ans l'unité d'élite de la
gendarmerie nationale le GIGN 1973 oui
en
1973 et alors en commun l'un et l'autre
la musique et principalement donc la
musique du gauffret vous êtes vraiment
un fan de la première heure absolument
oui j'ai commencé à chanter du gfry à 16
ans et pour j'étais éclaireur de France
à cette épo là voilà et vous étiez près
des feux de bois voilà et qu'est-ce que
vous aimez vous dans les chansons du
gaufret j'aime ce côté qui rassemble
parce que les chansons on les chante
tous donc ça c'est important au gène on
partait s'entraîner sur le terrain et il
mettait toujours ma guitare dans dans la
voiture donc il y
avait tout tout mon
personnel on partait jamais sans sans la
guitare et il connaissaiit tout ce
répertoire de HUG et puis c'est vous qui
leur avit appris non il le
connaiss tout le monde le connaissait
Céline à staluego il les connaissait
tous ces chansons comment vous expliquez
que vous plaisiez à ce point
militaire vous qui quand même parce que
Dylan n'était pas vraiment Bob Dylan
n'aimait pas trop quand même les
militaires ouais ça serait c'est trop
simplificateur ce gen ch mais Bob Dylan
Bob Dylan est un homme un homme de paix
et moi je continue à dire que les hommes
des militaires sont là pour pour
maintenir la la paix vous vous avez fait
votre service militaire absolument dans
le 27e bataillon chassur alpin je suis
très fier oui très fier j'ai terminé
comme caporal chef amusant de l'entendre
parce que vous que l'on prénomme un peu
le loup solitaire marginal plutôt seul
et tout finalement vous aimez bien les
l'équipe oui j'aime j'aime rentrer c'est
c'est c'est-à-dire que moi je je
j'aurais tendance la meut moi j'aime
bien la meut ah oui c'est le paradoxe
total non c'est pas le paradox Chef Chef
dans la meute quand même hein peut-être
le dominant mais pas le chef dominant
quand même quand on vous voit l'un à
côté de l'autre il passe vraiment pour
un timide à côté très
mais c'est un non mais quand je commande
je le suis
pas c'est dur
d'être ça se mérite m C cela dit quand
on le voit franchement il pourrait en
faire partie
hein perdre quand même quelques kilos je
me suis vu tout à l'heure je dis faut il
va falloir je Perre des kilos mais il
est taillé pour il il est taillé pour et
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose qui
lui aurait plu parce que il y a un dans
dans le augène et à travers les valeurs
que que des F HUG dans ses chansons il y
a quand même d'abord le fait que les
hommes sont son sont fédérés autour
d'idées fortes il dit tout il parle des
hommes il parle de l'amitié il parle de
l'amour il parle de la nature quel est
votre d'ailleurs chanson préférée debout
les gars par exemple tout tous les ça ça
oui ça ça ça ne m'étonne pas qu'on
chante ça euh dans la jandarmerie j'ai
de Bou lesgar éveillez-vous absolument
il y a une chose aussi qu'il faut faut
dire c'est que connaissant Christian
Prouteau j'ai j'ai découvert un homme
d'une grande modestie d'une grande
gentillesse un vrai gentil fragile même
dans son intérieur le chef du GIGN
pendant longtemps est un sentimentalur
fragile chronique c'est vrai oui ouiou
alors comment vous vous êtes rencontré
et bien moi j'avais un ami qui qui était
un pass qui est un des plus grands
restaurateurs de voiturees anciennes
mais moi je connais très bien hugof Fry
si tu veux on va pouvoir le rencontrer
il m'a amené un de ces spectacles on
s'est on s'est vu tout de suite sypathis
on a sympathisé oui chu oui alors vous
avez apporté ça c'est formidable tous
les deux vos guitares des guitares
qu'est-ce que vous allez chanter ben moi
on voulait chanter stall ou vous allez
vous asseoir sur le rebord ça sera mieux
il sa
st céit un cheval
blanc il était mon
idole et moi j'avais 10
ans notre pauvre
père pour acheter ce pur
sang
hab dans
l'affaire jusqu'à son dernier
franc bravo bravo à tous les deux pour
ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina mire
Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
cloche